so um so yeah i'm gonna talk to you
today about
applying the rl and more specifically
how to apply
multi-arm bandits um and yeah
um yeah nick gave an intro so
um about my profile so i'm gonna skip
the boring part
um so yeah we we all know you know
this uh fun stuff that you can do with
rl but you know you can play games
uh like pac-man and all this stuff
and probably most of you have already
you know heard or played with you know
dqm
um or you know uh this poor guy was
defeated by
you know alphago some years ago and
um you know it was powered you know the
algorithm was powered reinforcement
level
um and you know reinforcement learning
you know is a part of
ai and um it's different from supervised
learning where you know
you give label data and you train a
model
um
[Music]
where you the algorithm learns by trial
and error
so there is some exploration
exploitation uh dilemma going on
uh of you know if i'm playing chess
uh should i continue doing the same
moves or should i try something new and
then
something completely new and potentially
uh
you know win the game um so there is a
rewarding mechanism there
um and so um the key concept scenario is
that you have a state
an action and a reward and
given the state the algorithm will make
some decision
will take some action and you see that
there is a dotted line between action
and reward because usually the reward is
very sparse if you're playing chess
or go uh the reward of you
winning the game um it's gonna be
delayed
um and that makes it quite um
hard to be used in um real world
applications
in e-commerce and something that works
and i've seen being you know i've seen
working uh is multi-umbilics where
essentially you you can relax some
um of of the stuff that you've seen
before
so you can have context-free but they
have multi-armed mandates i'm gonna talk
about contextual ones
later so suppose that you don't have any
state
you still have the environment and um
you have a rewarding mechanism and you
can take some actions
or arms uh this term is usually
um used in multi-unbandits
and white bandits i mean
this whole thing was inspired by slot
machines and let's see that you're a
gambler
let's see that we have also infinite
amount of money
and someone told you that you know one
of these slot machines
has um uh the highest
expected probability to win money so
what you're doing is that you know you
don't know which one is it
so you know the first thing that comes
to your mind is you know
i'm gonna dedicate some time on the
first lock machine
and see how many times i want something
how many times i lost
then i'll go to the next slot machine
and then the third and the fourth etc
obviously this greedy approach doesn't
lead
to a really good solution um
it's just an approximate solution and
you get a reward here you see that it's
immediate
so uh the other thing that i forgot to
mention is that uh
you see that the line between action and
reward is not dotted
uh so that means that you know uh
we have the assumption that the reward
is immediate after you you choose an
action
or an arm um
and guess what uh you know the same
thing can be used
on selecting the best you know hero
image
on your homepage for example i chose
amazon here because i think most of you
are familiar with the concept
um you see here um the chosen one says
simplify your tv experience
fire tv stick etc but this is also a
carousel
so it has more options and how do you
choose
which one should be uh the winner should
be used most of the times
um you don't have any training data
um this candidate said can change
every month or two months um
and um then how do you define you know
what's the best one
potentially your reward here can be any
progress to uh progress to any page
uh yes with a hypothesis that if you
have something that
is appealing to most people will make
them click on configs
on things
another example is that let's say that
you know i searched for
um t-sets for men here
and we see four results um
in the results um
so as as someone that uh wants to sell
search and appears on these results how
do you choose which emails should be
shown on the results essentially
which image should be shown here that
will increase the probability that
you're going to click
on an item on on a on a product here
um and if you go
to i'm going to switch now if you go
here
and i click on this product you'll see
that
this product has many different images
and essentially every product can be
assigned with a can be assigned a
multi-unbounded model
but essentially the arms are the
different kind with images and the
reward is
the click-through rate
and i've seen that working really well
um
and there are many other applications uh
for example
let's say that you are netflix and
there are today 200 trending movies
um so how are you gonna show the top 10
you don't want to show 200 movies to
your users
but you can use multi-um bandits here
and what you can say is that
my pool of training movies is 200 so i
have 200 arms for actions
and the reward is click on any
of the top 10 trending movies for
example
[Music]
and then select the best email subject
line
this is very it's a classic one um
i i've been to meetings where people
were discussing and saying oh
you should use this subject line i think
it's better of the other one on the
third one
etc um sometimes uh
the person that is you know that has the
fattest salary will decide which one
will be
chosen uh but if we want to be truly
data-driven what we can say is that we
have some experts that say
that will generate these different
subject lines let's say
10 or 20 that align with you know
companies values and then we can let the
boundary to do the last mile
optimization
essentially the choose the subject line
that will increase
the open email rate and that's the
reward
another one uh it's to select the
frequency
of notifications after a user has viewed
the product
let's say that i was on the amazon app
um i checked a product
um and then for some other reason i
haven't purchased it
so what you can say is that okay um
i want as a as a marketeer i want to
send a notification to this person to
remind them
that this product is still available and
it's still on sale let's see
so the question is should i send that
after 15 minutes
30 minutes 60 minutes 300 minutes
later so these different frequencies can
be the arms
and the reward can be click on
notification
um and um something that
by the way i think that john lankford is
the father of contextual bandits
uh he he works for microsoft and he is
one of the
uh biggest uh
contributors to vocal wabbit
and he says that you have an rl problem
with the data that you want to learn on
is created by the solution
so that's uh that's what i always use as
an as a true nor to decide if something
is conceived can be
solved with bandits or not
um there are many videos from john
langford that says that the traditional
rl doesn't work
in practice in e-commerce uh use cases
uh he's a big fan of contextual bandits
um so let's let's move on the map
definition
um what we want to achieve
in this um in the classic map problem
is that we have k arms so okay different
images uh candidate images for the home
base for example
and t rounds uh we assume that
uh we have a specific
time frame to define the arm that has
the highest reward
so essentially in each round an
algorithm picks an
arm and then the output in the
environment
um we get feedback from the environment
as a high reward we assume that the word
is binary here for the chosen arm
and then the algorithm learns through
this process
and what you want to achieve is
essentially minimize regret
or maximize reward these things are
essentially the same thing and regret
means that
um if if there was an oracle algorithm
that for some reason
knew the actual uh reward rates for its
arm
uh this algorithm will always choose the
best arm right
so the regret for this algorithm will be
zero
um so all the other algorithms will have
a regret that is non-zero
so the goal is to find the algorithm
that will have
the minimum regret and that essentially
translates
into max reward
so um a classic um algorithm is the beta
thomson sampling
it's a essential bayesian algorithm
where you want to maximize the
cumulative reward
and you update the posterior of each arm
from the rewards that it receives from
the environment
um i'm not going to spend time a lot in
theory and just doing a quick summary
assume that either you know or you can
read papers or articles out there that
probably explain things um much better
than i do
um but the idea is that essentially
every arm is
um is assigned the beta distribution
and um essentially the algorithm
draws a value from this beta
distribution
and selects the arm with the highest
theta so theta is the the the number
that is true
but it drew it was drawn from the beta
distribution
so essentially every arm at the
beginning can
look something like that there be the
distributions can look something like
that
um i assume i gave as a
you know as a prior uh to the beta
distributions the parameters
of a and b to be equal to one uh this is
debatable
i've seen people are chosen uh
alpha and beta to be dot one
uh but yeah we can argue about that you
know four hours
and then let's say that you know some
arm let's say arm two
the slot machine two or the hero image
uh candy here image 2 or the um
subject line r2 had uh
20 words and 10 uh 20 positive rewards
and 10 negative rewards
so essentially then the distribution for
this arm would look
will look like that and every time you
draw a number
from this distribution and
and you make decisions and ultimately
at the at the end of a specific
um period uh you want the distributions
to look like that
to be very narrow uh essentially to have
you know low variance
uh in order to to say that you know my
arms have converged the algorithm has
converged
and then you can compare all these
different bit distributions and you can
say okay
um arm4 is the best one uh
because it's on the most right-hand side
uh
if you if you put them all together
there
um so let's go and you know
in real world let's say we're in a you
know
company and we managed to sell this idea
to our manager
and the manager to the to the vp etc
and uh they say okay you have three
weeks
to build the poc and prove that this
thing works
so no pressure um so
first thing that you need to do with
your product manager
is to decide okay what's the definition
of the best
arm of the best hero image so
we agree it's the one that increases the
probability of a user progressing to any
next space
i want people to progress to any next
page
because the assumption the hypothesis
that we make is that this
here image that is on top will make the
website more appealing more attractive
more relevant you name it and makes
people to
search more on the homepage scroll down
and eventually click on something
um what are the arms the candid images
so who is going to create all these
candidate images
um this is true story uh
companies still there generate
they have a product team or content team
that generates hundreds of candidate
images for products
for home for home page landing pages etc
and the problem is that they have so
many
that they cannot run a traditional ap
test
uh because it will take probably years
even if you have the traffic of amazon
to to reach us that is
a significant result so usually it's
chosen in a qualitative way but they're
equally all really good
um i mean aesthetically
so um let's assume that the product team
has created these kind of images
that's the best thing to do to get them
involved
this one and tell them that all
of them to be considered as candidates
they should be aesthetically nice
they should meet the minimum criteria
that the company
has okay
how the hell we're gonna integrate that
with the front end
so last problem with data scientists
okay i have something i have simulation
locally
okay and then you know people tell you
okay i want this to be a running
production
so um one solution that
could work is to have the sampling logic
essentially you make um a recommendation
and you say
at this specific uh time step you should
do this specific user you should show
these hero images uh can be done through
a restful service
and you can have an endpoint that would
look like
like this post sample
um and then okay so essentially the
front end before they render the
home page they will call our service
to uh get a recommendation from
our bandit which aims to show obviously
it should be super fast
um and um yeah i've been to situations
where
the 95th percentile response time
for this one was 50 milliseconds
so uh you need to be careful because if
it's slow then it doesn't matter the
user experience is really bad
okay how the front end will provide
feedback
so um the front end can post
only positive feedback if you think
about this they can say that
i showed image 20 and the person
the user at the time uh progressed to
some
next page and then at that point the
front end
asynchronously can send this video
feedback plus
um and we're gonna update the model but
the negative feedback
um cannot be sent because if someone
views
um here image on the homepage
and they don't like it and look like the
la the website they will bounce
and you you cannot capture that it's
it's almost
impossible it's really hard so what you
can do
is essentially you can define some uh
kind of timeout and you can say that you
know if i don't receive any positive
feedback
in 30 minutes for these specific emails
i assume that it was a bad choice
for the user
and uh before i go to the next step um
how you
define this timeout um so
what you can do is that you can do some
um
explore exploratory data analysis on the
log data of your home page
and you can see in user sessions
uh measure what's the time
in seconds or milliseconds between the
time that someone lands on the homepage
in the time that they go to the next
page and what you can say okay
i'm going to calculate the 90th
percentile of the 95th percentile of
that and we can say okay the 95th
percentile
of somebody landing on the homepage and
then moving on another page
is 15 minutes so then you can set the
timeout 15 minutes
because you assume that the last five
percent are yeah oh
it's outliers
okay so the most difficult question
is that okay how are you going you're
going to prove that it works
because in e-commerce uh people use a b
test platforms
and they they use uh kpis
there to say if a specific feature or
algorithm or whatever
increases click-through rate conversion
money you name it
but how are you going to approve that
here
um so what you're gonna do is that
you're gonna still run an a b test
but in the control you have the current
status quo
so the time static here image
that is selected by the product team
in the treatment group you're using the
bandwidth service
but essentially has a pool of let's say
30 images and then what you can do is
that you can use the a b test platform
and say if the um
if the bandit um has operated better
than the
control in terms of the click through
the click-through rate
uh essentially the progression to the
next
so you can measure that and you you
should reach
the statistically significant result and
then you are like
95 99 sure that it works
and then you can measure other kpis you
can see this
um immediately work that you have of
essentially pushing people
to the next page and potentially that
means pushing people
down the funnel the shopping the
shopping funnel it is also increasing
conversions purchases and that's really
cool because essentially
you can prove that you make more people
to click and at the same time
you can say to the senior leader say
okay
i made this amount of money
and then you can get the green light to
go and do more cool stuff
so architecturally
will look something like that
essentially
the front end will decide
for every user if this user is going to
be in control or treatment
uh so i make the assumption that you
know in your business you have a mature
a b test platform here
and if the user that lands on the home
page is assigned to the treatment group
that means that the front end is going
to call our rest api
and the request body will have the user
id so i'll use the uid
here and the user id can be
um um either someone has logged in
and we have their unique identifier or
if if
they're you know they're a new user uh
you can
use them equity or something like that
to essentially
say that you know this potential is a
new user
um and then the response of our rest api
will look
something like that you'll see later why
i use the user id
you understand later because you you
tell me you don't use that
when you sample from the beta terms or
something right
um and then the response body will look
like this
where you say r might be is image three
and that can be like the url of emails
and you have also decision id so this
specific
uh sampling action action is
essentially assigned a decision id in
our back end
you see later why this is important
it's important because then we can link
our decisions to the feedback
essentially the front end let's say that
you know
image 3 was really nice for this
specific user
so that means that they progress to the
next page so
then um what you're doing as a front-end
guy
you're sending us feedback and the
feedback should contain the user id
the arm id and the decision id
and then on the back end what we do is
we say okay what was our decision id
we find the decision id was image3 okay
that's good so that's a double
verification at the front end
that don't have a series back there and
also i'm going to assign a feedback
i'll create a new feedback log
in my log data that will say image3 had
the feedback repository
and essentially then what you're going
to do
is uh you can have some form of
scheduled job
that essentially um reads the log data
that leave in some storage
um i don't use any closes here it's up
to you to decide
it's conceptual it has the decisions and
the feedbacks
and the schedule job can be scheduled uh
the interval can be equal to the
timeout a time that we have decided
when to sign a negative reward
essentially what does this mean is that
let's call them
orphan um decisions on the decisions and
feedback store
they will be assigned a negative
feedback immediately
and then the scheduled job will update
the model will update essentially the
beta params
a and b for each arm and we'll update
them on the rest
api
and one more thing what about if the
user comes back to the home base after
three minutes
or refreshes the page it's going to be a
really bad user experience if
if every time they refresh the
uh um the hero image changes
and i've measured that in
uh a test tests using a b test
and uh the results were really bad so
that's why
you need the user id um or some entity
id
where essentially you say okay for this
user i have made a decision
and it should say stain some consistency
casts
for some specific time
so the time is ttl usually this is how
it's called uh in caches so time to
leave
i can say okay this is going to leave
there for five minutes or ten minutes
so this usually uh depends on the use
case and um it's good to ask the product
manager
because they usually know they have more
domain knowledge about that
than you
and um yeah then
should i implement these beta terms on
something myself
or not um my my uh line here is that
you know up to the beta thumbs on
something you can do it yourself
uh but don't go further uh try to use
open source libraries and we are really
lucky because
tf agents they have um a dedicated
uh part in their library with uh
contextual bandits uh which is
really cool and the reason is that you
shouldn't implement it probably yourself
is that um tf agents has 86 contributors
essentially 86 google employees
uh so they're getting paid to do full
time this uh whereas probably
yourself not going to do that full time
uh so their quality of code will be
like nine percent uh better than yours
and vocal rabbit that's another cool um
tool it also supports as you probably
know supervised
algorithms but it has a section for
uh multi-unbanded contextual multi-arm
bandwidths
uh it's more mature than tf agents
personally i prefer it it's i think it's
a personal
taste and has a 128 contributors and i
think the vast majority of them are
microsoft employees
and one of them is john lankford
so yeah i would suggest to use
those two when you say okay bit
attention something works is amazing
i've proven to to the senior leaders if
that works
and then they tell you okay let's move
on
and have something contextual
um and then okay how about adversarial
adversarial bandits
uh like exp3 so the the band is that the
beta delson sampling assumes that we
live in a stationary environment
during this um time
period the t steps the number of t steps
uh it doesn't change uh which is not
entirely true
in some use cases so let's say if you
are booking or expedia
uh and you have a hero emails on the
home page you have the environment
changes
you cannot have a snowy image there 12
for 12 months
if you have that you know somebody lands
there yeah nobody is going to
make any booking uh in normal days
before calling
so um
what about adversary bandits they look
but you know these things can work and
they adapt to the environment
they usually convert much much slower
obviously because
they assume that there's some other
party there that tries to trick them
but the tricky part is that it's really
really hard to prove
to business that they work because
essentially you have to run a long a b
test
for three months or four months while
the environment changes
and you can say during this time that um
yeah
my adversarial bandit works
but you have to leave it around for a
long time
so i wouldn't go there probably
something that works and i talk to
some some friends that work in big tech
companies
they usually reset the bandit with new
candidates
every week or every month and they run a
new one
um so yeah we have like now contextual
multi-unbandits that i talked
uh just like before
so essentially uh what you want to do is
that you can use this thing
as a feature vector to decide what's the
best action
arm that will maximize the reward so
essentially
in the hearing image problem your
context can be the time of the day
um what type of browser they're using
if it is mobile or desktop then you can
say oh for mobile
and on safari um image 4 is the best one
but for a safari and desktop image
15 is the best one
oh by the way sometimes you run the
context
always is really really important to run
the context-free boundary first
i've seen situations where i run a
contextual one right later
and it didn't uh prove to be better in
the
test readout
and that's i think most of the cases the
problem is that you know
we have chosen the wrong
features and
it's really tricky to go and find what
are the the
best state features um that you should
use
uh you should then try and do something
called
off policy evaluation and use the
existing log data
from previously deployed band-aids to
try
to bias them and then link them with
what would have been the state back then
and three run different algorithms
i'm not getting into that um it can be
like a complete
different talk um
as i said the what's the difference with
the context uh
uh three boundaries that the contextual
ones um essentially the state of the
environment is a feature vector
they call it um context essentially
literature that's by contextual
uh bandits and as i said yeah in the
previous use case
the context could be if the person is a
new user time of the day
country code browser type
mobile or desktop etc
there are even advanced settings where
the arms themselves can be associated
with features
uh vocal wabbits support this kind of
advanced settings by the way
so okay how like
if you know you shouldn't do that but
it's always a nice exercise um
in fact you shouldn't implement a
contextual bandit yourself you should do
this exercise um how about
if the um how we're going to implement
that
so um we can start thinking loud how we
can implement a contextual bandit
and use thompson sampling at the same
time
um what i'm going to give you here is
not like um
you know bulletproof solution um in
purpose i i just
did it in a rough way
and what you can do is that you can
assume that every arm
can be associated with some function
that is essentially a regression
function
and here okay i have one feature
and you have also the
the beta0 and you can divide the debate
if he should be added or not in bandits
i personally wouldn't add this
bias in the first place
but then what you assume what you can do
is you can say is that
every weight of the feature
is um are distributed as independent
gaussians
and then um you can
say that you express your reward as the
probability of reward for its arm to be
of this form right now
and that gives you the ability because
every time
that you make during the sampling logic
every time that you make a sampling
logic you sample from these
independent gaussian distributions for
its weight
then you form your function then you run
run it through the features that you
have
and then uh you get this the value and
then
finally you get the uh the probability
and that means that you can use a
thompson something logic on top of that
um and then you can read this paper and
see how you can update these weights
um chappelle has a you know really nice
proof about that
um and essentially it's
you can use directly the
equations to that he has proved to
update your model
or you can use an open source library
and then what will change on your deploy
deployed model now that you move to
contextual validates um
yeah first of all you're gonna use uh an
open source library if asians or vw
your background schedule job
will be responsible still to get the log
data from the log store and
incrementally train contextual bandit
and updated on rest api
so the background job doesn't now send
any more
the a and beta the alpha and beta
uh parameters to the
rest api but you can send the serialized
model directly
and now the front end during the
sampling phase
is is responsible to push the context
features to the endpoint
um and here's some really cool papers
essentially
i think the vast majority of them are
applied i mean uh the first one is from
duolingo
the second one for booking the third one
is yahoo
um the last one is from amazon
so they essentially deployed these
solutions
uh to production and they're going to be
really successful
i think the last one from amazon they
claimed that they increased the
conversion by
uh 17 something crazy i don't want to
to do the rough calculations of you know
how much money means to them
and some other resources is that tf
agents has a really cool
uh tutorial for bandits same for volvo
rabbit
and something that i really like um
azure has a sas service
essentially for contextual bandits and
context free bandits
uh essentially john langford
uh uses uh the vocal wabbit behind the
scenes on this one
and he's a microsoft employee and um
i've done some i've done some pocs and
it's really cool because they give you
some extra tooling some dashboarding how
the arms perform
uh if you know if you get the logs
correctly and all this stuff
because don't forget at some point
uh you need lots of engineering work to
continue doing that and yeah i'm
currently leading the
reinforcement learning team at expedia
group and
i i can tell you that um we have
software engineers in the team but also
the data scientists should have really
strong engineering
skills uh because it's uh
yeah it's challenging from from
engineering perspective as well
um and other cool applications of mods
i've done some pocs to device existing
ml models
essentially what you can do there is
that
you can take existing classifiers and
during production
you can use the map framework to
try and explore a little bit
uh during the decision making and the
bias your
training data because usually you get
into this loop where
you use training data that is generated
from your previous model
essentially you don't make any progress
and i would highly suggest to watch this
uh
youtube video from a striped guy
who explains how
they buy us the training data for the
fraud detection algorithm and the same
thing for search engine for a ranking
mode
excuse me ranking model
from a paper that is jointly written by
microsoft and facebook
and that's all folks thank you
cool that was a
super publish i like the handy tips
you give every time in the depth you
cover the topic
i have some questions but i don't want
to start is anyone else
with a question you can ask i mean i
incentivize that you open the mic and
ask but if you don't want to do that you
can also
ask in the chat
no worries i say
and i can kick off
with one question
i'm trying to understand the difference
with um
supervised learning um i think to a
certain extent you gave us the answer
uh nib testing right so i think for a b
testing
uh it makes sense that at times you
might have a lot of options
[Music]
possibly with supervised learning the
problem could be the same
i guess that you know you don't have the
data when you start
sort of wanting to create the model and
maybe multi-arm bandwidth gets you into
the solution quicker but
um yes what is the difference
with the if you can offer some comments
on this and then also how applicable is
it
in the case where some of these
restrictions don't apply
for example the example you showed us
first they had only six images right so
choosing among those is not and also
probably these are static images or some
seller
uh uploaded them so you can
get data on them and do a supervised
model so
how does it compare this technique
compared to a situation where you can
also do something else
um so yeah first part of the question
um so the i mean the difference is that
in supervised learning you you have some
ground truth so you have some
some some label data some features
these labels and you assume that you
know you have a really good
representation of the world
this is a really good sample and then
you say okay i can train a model there
in the contextual multi-unbalance
because i think that's more
uh kind of related
uh you still have some features but you
don't have the labels you don't know
for which feature what should be
uh feature values which is the best
image right
so you can say this is like a
multi-class uh
uh problem multi-class classification
problem
uh and essentially what you're doing is
that um
in the rough example that i showed you
about the
um linear terms on sampling at the end
you use the thomson sampling methodology
to explore
and essentially improve your your
training data essentially
during production with exploration
exploitation and ultimately
lead you to the right model
so you don't have the answer you don't
know what's the best essentially
class if you want to make it you know
relate to be related to supervised
learning you know what's the what's the
right class for your future values
um and um the last uh the other part of
your question about
uh you you said that you know let's say
that you you have you sell a product on
amazon and you
upload the images um
i mean still you cannot build the
supervised model there because you have
to say to the seller
what you what essentially if you want to
build the supervised model there
or in the homepage use case
you have to tell the business okay we're
gonna randomly
choose images for a month
we're going to grab feedback and then
i'm going to build the model
you know what's the answer no because
and that's a good answer because it's
very risky
because many of these images may perform
really bad
and if you equally split the traffic
uh you have a high risk for the business
and that's
that's the the nice part about the
boundaries because quickly
eliminate bad actions but others
okay very interesting any other
questions
i'm very keen to hear other perspectives
on this
i'm very happy to keep hammering you
with questions of course yeah
i think they watch the game yes everyone
is in two screens i'm sure
um you definitely answer another
question i've written which is you know
what libraries to use right you cover
that
i was like okay i'm pretty sure there is
a library so that was nice to see
okay another question i had was um i
mean essentially follow up on the
previous one right so
essentially what i meant was say that we
have a way to sample
i mean what you said or a b test right
like with a randomly assigned images i'm
not saying that the business will select
that but uh you know just for
um for the theoretical conversation
let's say we randomly sample
or a b test and collect data on which
images perform best
can we compare the multi-arm bandwidth
solution to which one performs better to
a supervised model and
and would one would both perform the
same
and the adjacent to this question is is
one going to perform
at a certain level of accuracy quicker
so for example multi-arm bandwidth do
they require less data for the same
performance than
a supervised connection or the other way
around is there is there any
discussion on that somewhere in the
paper
just to clarify the question so you mean
that let's say that for some reason we
have a
classic supervised model right for a for
a problem
um or let's say we collect data i mean
we have a way to collect data
so that we can compare so theoretically
the supervised model should perform
better
in v8 you'll see better um
result on the a b test readout after you
run the a b test
because you already choose the best
actions
whereas the bandit essentially for some
time
it will make some sub-optimal decisions
because it learns
and that will affect the readout and um
as i follow up there is that let's say
that we don't do that and we have like
the static key raymans and we have the
multi-arm bandit in the a b test uh
what is usually a really good um
practice is that you run the first day
because
you may see that the bandit the
treatment may not have
necessarily the best performance
because i've seen cases where the
exploration time had to be lengthy and
that had the cost
the customers but it wasn't so bad so
there was a story where essentially what
we was happening is that
somebody from an ap test uh platform i
made me some point and said what are you
doing in this a b test
the you know the sales results
click-through rate is terrible
in your treatment just shut it down um
and then you have you know take a deep
breath breath and you can say okay
you know you have to analyze the
band-aids what they're doing
and essentially see
how the weights because it was a
contextual one how the weights
these independent gaussians behave and
you i was seeing that they were getting
narrow and narrower
and i said you know give me like you
know one more week
um and you have to explain that um
and uh then what you do is that you turn
off the a b test
uh at some point when it's statistically
significant
and what you do is that you take these
you
you run a follow up a b test with a
static best solution solutions
static best arms where you say for this
context that was the best arm for the
other context the other half
and then essentially your treatment
always chooses the best
options and this is where you see the
true effect on your business
super i feel we can talk forever anyone
else wants to
[Music]
jumping
just just one before i go i i i
almost went away but one question i do
you know
whether um other companies so
use this approach in in production and
in what other ways i don't know maybe
i've missed i've missed some of the
talk at some point so i was wondering
how um
how usual is this approach instead of
more uh
kind of supervised techniques let's say
i think it's kind of new um so that
expedia we use it
booking use this technique amazon
netflix a lot microsoft
facebook a lot i think for the
advertising uh system
um i think the big tech companies
use these techniques a lot um but
that mean that's because they have lots
of traffic right
so if you want to use the bandwidth you
have to have traffic to make it converge
if you have i don't know 30 users per
day
this thing will never convert so
um so yeah it's it's kind i think it's
kind of new
that's why tf agents uh library is very
new
in bandits the only one that existed
before that was mobile rabbit
because of langford um i think we'll see
more and more
use cases applicable use cases in the
future
so yeah cool okay cool
thanks yeah sure
any other burning questions
i've lost my last question for you
and i said i don't have any other that's
all everything and
in regards to contextualized funding
even for the non-contextualized one but
maybe more so for
are there any people uh or efforts that
use more complicated models than
gaussians or beta distributions that you
said so maybe neural net or some sort of
machine learning model that estimates
the parameters from all this sampling
that
is going on yeah um
i think the tf agent has this
implementation you can use a neural
network
essentially and uh what what
it does for exploration so in neural
network you know during training you
usually
use dropout for avoiding avoiding
overfitting
so what they do is that during inference
essentially during sampling
they do drop out in order to enforce
exploration
so um so that's i think one of the most
advanced things i've seen
and it's you can use it in the entity of
agents library
um i even played myself and you know i
created some local simulations
where i created my own pythons on neural
network
and to find fun with fighters uh where
essentially what i did is that i created
a
fully connected neural network super
simple to
do that uh two layers um
and um in the last layer
you have the different choices for arts
let's say you know 10 20 whatever
and then at the end what you do is that
you can do something you can use softmax
uh in order to to sample the
uh you use thompson sampling on top of
softmax
so um i think i have existing github
on this one if i don't i'll upload it
but
uh yeah it works on simulation armor if
you work
in real world i assume it needs many
more data
um to be many more much more traffic
than
for the other techniques converge yeah
yeah absolutely yeah yeah
i would go for the linear one uh even
the amazon paper
in the list is a linear model um
and yeah it worked for me
super well if anyone has a question
and do ask
and if not we can call it today
what i'm gonna do is i'm going to um
stop the recording and upload the video
maybe in a week or two so
and you will have the opportunity to see
the slides and the talk again
if you have any other
things you want to tell us of course we
have the slack channel that chris shared
and and hopefully we'll see you in the
next um
in the next meetup we do you very much
pavlos thanks everyone
see you thank you see ya bye